well thank you and good afternoon
everyone it's great to be here in
Norfolk and let me start by saying I was
glad to support Nancy's campaign for the
House of Delegates
she is going to be a strong leader on
the big issue states in this community
and the whole state including climate
change and I'm happy to also say that I
supported 14 other Virginia Democrats
who also won election thanks to the good
work of so many volunteers and
supporters who knocked on doors and make
phone calls and got bogus to the polls
and in January Democrats will take
charge of the state government for the
first time in 25 years it's about time
in 19 or in 2018 I also supported two
congressional candidates here in
Virginia who won jennifer Wexton and
Elaine Gloria who represents this part
of the area and the surrounding strong
campaigns of the Democrats captured the
US House of Representatives and began
holding president Trump accountable for
his dangerous abuse of power and I think
that's one of the good news pieces of
good news that we've had recently now
you may ask why am i kicking my campaign
off right here in Norfolk and it is
because southeastern Virginia proves
that with the right candidate we can
turn areas from red to blue and we need
to do that all across this country and
today I'm glad to announce that I am
running for president to defeat Donald
Trump and unite and rebuild America we
cannot afford four more years of
president Trump's reckless and unethical
actions he is an existential threat to
our country to our values and our
national security and every day it seems
to bring another example of just how
unfit he is to serve as our president
and commander-in-chief and this week was
no exception yesterday many of you read
the president forced out the Secretary
of the Navy a Marine veteran for
upholding the military's commitment to
the rule of law secretary Spencer wrote
and I quote I cannot in good conscience
obey an order that I believe violates
the sacred oath I took to support and
defend the Constitution of the United
States unquote that's an extraordinary
rebuke and here in this city which is
home to the world's largest naval base
I salute secretary Spencer for not
flinching from his duties but the fact
remains we have a president a
commander-in-chief who has no respect
for the rule of law and no concern
whatsoever for ethics or honor or for
the values that truly make America great
if President Trump wins another term in
office we may never recover from the
damage that he can do the stakes could
not be higher we must win this election
and we must begin rebuilding America by
investing here at home and restoring our
nation's credibility and moral
leadership abroad I believe my unique
set of experiences in business
government and philanthropy will enable
me to both win and to lead as a
candidate I'll rally a broad and diverse
coalition to win and as president I'll
have the skills to fix what is broken in
our great nation and there is a lot
broken we have an economy that is tilted
against most Americans we have a health
care system that costs too much and
doesn't cover everyone we have
communities ravaged by gun violence
including here in this region
sadly mass shootings like the one
earlier this year just 17 miles from
here in Virginia Beach that become
almost routine we cannot accept that we
have to put an end to this madness
you
hundreds of millions of dollars fighting
the NRA to when common sense gun laws
and I'm not stopping now across the
country we have schools that aren't
preparing our children for success in
the increasingly high-tech world we have
an immigration system that is cruel and
dysfunctional we have a climate change
that is growing worse by the day and we
have special interests that corrupt
Washington and block progress on all of
these issues as a child and a boy scout
I was taught to believe in the promise
and potential of America and I've never
been more worried about its future than
I am today America is at its best when
we work together to find meaningful and
lasting solutions to our big challenges
we need a president who understands that
truth and who can do it rather than just
make promises and I offer myself as a
problem solver and a doer not a talker
and as someone who is ready to take on
the tough fights and win we say we have
to beat Trump now I took on Trump on gun
violence and won stronger than laws and
states across the country I took on
Trump the climate denier and have led
efforts that have closed more than half
of the nation's dirty qualified power
plants Trump right now is carrying one
of a big tobacco I've taken on the
dangers of e-cigarettes to protect our
kids I know what it takes to beat Trump
because I already have and I will do it
again defeating Trump and rebuilding
America is the most urgent and important
fight of our lives and I'm going all-in
my resolve is to stand up to the bigotry
and hatred and wrongheaded policies that
his anger he is anchored in and in my
belief in government as good as a force
for good I've spent my career bringing
people together to tackle big problems
and fix them it has worked well in
business and in running the country's
largest most
city and it can work in Washington as
well let me just tell you a little bit
about myself growing up my father had
never earned more than six thousand
dollars a year I managed to work my way
through college and got an entry-level
job in New York and then when I was 39
years old I got laid off I didn't know
what to do next but I did have an idea
to start a company so I took a chance
and today I'm glad to say our company
employs 20,000 people and generates law
large profits all of which go to helping
people across the country and around the
world
my company's employees get well paid we
provide the best health care benefits
that money can buy and if someone in our
family has a baby
they primary caregiver gets six months
paid maternity leave I'll run my company
according to my values honestly with
integrity fairness and inclusion and
that's the same thing that I brought to
city government I first ran for mayor
because when I looked around I became
more and more frustrated with stories of
senseless gun violence failing schools
and lack of opportunity for those who
are poor or who were discriminated
against because of their race religion
or gender most people said to me well
that's just the way it is and I said to
myself why why can't we do better well
rather than just complain about it why
don't we do something about it and so
that's exactly what I did I was lucky
enough to be elected mayor of new
America's most diverse city just weeks
after the attacks of 9/11 it really was
a frightening time for our city and our
country but we rebuilt the economy with
new jobs and opportunity for people are
all rungs of the
clatter we work with our teachers to
negotiate the largest raise in America
and we improve graduation rates working
together by 42% we cut murders in half
while reducing incarceration by nearly
40% we also cut the city's carbon
footprint by 14% and created new
programs to combat poverty and we
expended health care and strengthen the
immigrant communities as mayor my
priority was helping the millions of New
Yorkers who needed it the most now I
know government can improve people's
lives because when I ran New York City
that's exactly what we did and we should
never settle for anything less this is
America since leaving City Hall
I found the largest gun safety group in
history and I created a campaign to take
on the biggest polluters and climate
threats as mayor I've been smoking in
restaurants and bars and then cut seen
smoking by 50% and today we continue to
win battles against the tobacco industry
and their sleazy attempts to put young
kids on e-cigarettes now I know how to
take on the powerful special interests
that corrupt Washington I know how to
win because I've done it time and again
we need a president who is ready to lead
us where we need to go in a ways that we
can be proud of someone with the
experience to hit the ground ready to go
I am that person and that's why I'm
running I will be the only candidate in
this race who isn't going to take a
penny from anyone and will work for $1 a
year just as I did for 12 years in New
York City Hall over the course of this
campaign I will tell you what I'll do as
president and how I will do it a lot of
I'm plans for creating good-paying jobs
providing quality health care for every
American
stopping gun violence reducing
incarceration fighting climate change
fixing our broken immigration system
raising taxes on wealthy individuals
like me protecting women's and LGBTQ
rights supporting our veterans
and reestablishing America's place in
the world as a force for peace and
stability but more than plans I offer
the leadership to term plans into
reality to roll up my sleeves to
motivate our country G at night and
rebuild America and make it fair and
better I'm ready to get to work so let's
get it on we happy to take a question at
you sir you have your hand up I was
lucky enough to receive some very
flattering calls but it's just stay
between whoever made the call and if
they want to talk about it it's up to
them I certainly would not violate that
confidence but I didn't grow up in a
world where I knew famous people and
when you get a call from one of them I
still pinch myself a little bit a lot of
your Democratic opponents they're saying
you're jumping into this race you're
going to spending a lot of money that
they're accusing you sir of trying to
buy your way into this race Elizabeth
Warren had some tough words for you
today sir what would be your response to
that are you trying to buy the
presidency look the years I've been
using my resources for the things that
matter to me I was lucky enough to build
a successful company it has been very
successful and I've used all of it to
give back to help America I'm committed
to fight forgotten safety I'm committed
to fight for stopping climate change
which could is a disaster for us I'm
committed to doing things like I was
lucky enough to be able to help flip the
house from Democrat from Republican to
democratic control so that the house
provided some oversight of the president
which the Republican has
before that had not done that I was
using my mind to do these things like
turning Virginia from red to blue both
houses are now blue and a lot of it was
because of the monies that we provided
on gun safety one of the big issues that
were people cared about so now in the
race I'm fully committed to defeating
Donald Trump I think he's an existential
threat to our country I'm going to make
my case well let me phrase it this way I
think that there is a greater risk of
having Donald Trump re-elected than they
was before and in the end I've looked in
the mirror and said it just cannot let
this happen if you remember back at the
Democratic convention in Philadelphia in
2016 I said that Donald Trump was not
suited to be pressing the United States
unfortunately I guess not not what
people not enough people listen to me
but we have to do something about Donald
Trump I think I know how to beat him I
beat them a number of times before I
think I know what this country needs and
that's what I'm going to focus on yes
nobody knows but I think if I've come to
the conclusion that while impeachment is
a very serious thing and fundamentally
we should let the voters in the November
every time for years when it comes up
make a decision
I think the conduct that we have heard
described in these hearings is such that
if I were a congressman I would vote for
impeachment yes well I think that I've
done an awful lot of things that would
should attract people I work very hard
to make sure that we tackle
discrimination wherever I saw it New
York City has a record that not perfect
but I think is we should be proud of in
terms of making it a city open to
everyone I've been a very big supporter
of gay rights and step going against any
kind of discrimination that I've seen
anyplace worked very hard in minority
communities brought the crime rate down
and saved an awful lot of lives of
people who unfortunately we have high
crime we would have lost a lot of young
people and it's not I've never done
everything perfectly but I did the best
job I guess
you talk DNC about how that might work
no it's up to the DNC to they can set
the rules and if they set the rules
where I qualify I would certainly debate
if they set the rules where I don't
qualify then I won't but what I want to
do is talk directly to the public and
explain what I've done and what I would
do and give them some comfort that
because of what I did in the past
I will deliver in the future the next
empty promises and if you can say that
in a debate okay although it's hard to
do that I think I'd be much better off
talking to the public just like I'm
doing that going to Phoenix Arizona
tomorrow I have no idea but we're going
to do that test and it's called voting